大変お待たせいたしました
いい発表
はい通りだよ
夏へしたっけ遠い昔のように感じます2016年の4月4日
私はエンディング動画に飽きてしまったエンディング動画に飽きてしまって
エンディング動画の募集を掛けたところなんとありがたいことになんと
に全県とのエンディングどうかをいただければ
どうぞやろ
本当にありがとうございますこの動画を出した時当初はですねもう本当に動画をつける
のって大変なんでる何か多ければ100個ぐらいかなと思ってたんですけどももう本当
にありがたいことに1100本の動画を送って頂きまして僕の想像を遥かに超える量で
こんなに時間がかかってしまいました本当に遅くなって申し訳ないです
これたぶんですね僕だけじゃなくて上の人とか
はな人に手伝ってもらって協力してみれば結構すぐ終わったものだと思ったんですけど
エンディング動画っていうのは僕のチャンネルのエンディングなのでやっぱり僕のため
に作ってもらったので責任を持って僕自身が全てのエンディング動画を見ることに意味
があると思ったので応募してくださった動画僕が1人で全部責任を持ってみました甘
仲値公示感が取れなくてなんとか空いている時間にも1日何個でもいろいろ
ちょっと爪て今日という日を迎えることができました放題で僕のついにチャンネルの
新しいエンディングが決まります今使って連日がいいという声も多いんですけども僕
自身がきちゃってるんで
これを機にエンディングボスとかへ去ってもいいのかなと思いましたこういうがず
すべての動画を観させていただいたんですけどもすべての動画に番号ンって予定も悪く
もいいなと思った動画の番号だけピックアップして
いきました良くも悪くもねここは2用ビスというわけで本当は全部招待したいんです
けども曜日もいかないので奥が選び抜いたこのちょっとすごいと思った
良くも悪くもっと思った道がよくも悪くも追ってもっと動画今回はみんなが見ていき
ましょう
ドローンがどれにするかというのを決めてないんで今回でちゃんと見て決めようと思い
ます本当にもう4ヶ月かけて行った動画でくださ
余った俺みんなありがとう
まず1個目です
不採用もうこんな感じでどんどん見ていきますよ次行きましょうおりバルを使ってたん
ですよねこれは
主役がを言えばねみたいになってますね
もうなんかねチャンネルの書士が変わっちゃってますねこれはチャンネルみたいになっ
てるんですよ
最後はタイプ完全におかしいですよ
これにすごいよくできてるなと思ったんですよ
うん
シンブルこういうのは僕好きです結構
フィンでそっちか
を
これすごいんですよねなんか手書きというか木造り感が凄いなと思いますありがとう
ございます
次です
房代これはねー
顔がも完全にサイコパス某
すごいこれはすごいな美味いと思いましたん
もう
すげーよああ
けれども頭の出し方が高うまいんですよね次行っ所
両サイドが違いますよだいぶチャンネルかわかんないってきちゃってるからねぇ
とてる感じがすごい
あんなマレルミノアそこで既婚だろうもさなんてあるんですねつぎ
一言
大ない前に前回の動画をいじるって作戦ですね
普段よここあとは良く出来てるんだけどねなんで最初にもやしを持ってきたかな
ん
を
po po
のいい
よく回ったねあんなに
大
わー
おおーー
木彫り像たいですなこれすごいよねー
どうしたああすっげーりん増加が半端ないですよ
至近距離でも美しいですね防音いいよ
猫ちゃんが大いやホントよく出来てるよおお
結局高評価会
いや俺じゃないからね怒られちゃうよ俺が
をは落ち着いてね
e 4 a
やっちまったなぁ房代
をイヤーて買う前はよく出来てるな
次です
おおかわいい
r
goo
たくさんよ
うわぁすげぇ
k もうかっこいい
あるいは新人さんありがとうございますさ
真鍋フィンって書いてあったまあめっちゃ貼らないでさ
もう twitter ネッツが完全にここじゃねーか他の花というもんなんか全体で
有名なこの follow 俺ねをアイコンにもいい子みたいになってる山を下ネタ
ばっかり不採用
んを変えるだ腹ヤンキーみたいなちょっとずっっ
クマのライブバージョンんなーぐっ
ん
うん
なんでこの画像でしたう惚れちゃった
この曲みんな好きなのね堂園すげー綺麗だーなぁ
2件過ぎやり過ぎありがとうございます
なあ甘いよくまとまってるん前なみんな本当に
うびっくりしたわ俺惹かれてるんじゃ
を大
スウープ
ああああああ
4 o
すげーうまいなぁ表よくできたら凄い凄いん
おおおおうかっこいいラパスろいろ二次最後ど
フィニきもー僕の像法が詳しく載ってますねここに
次の方はこの方はですね大額なんですよね音楽を作ってくださった方です
ピーッ
癒す j 4
映像だけは他の人に対応して bgm もこの人のこのちょっとなめた音楽で対応する
っていうのをちょっとありかなとか思っています次
ぞとこれ怒られよ
わーん
なんでここ採用した
ええっ
すごいん
おおおおおお
猫のファミコンといいかんこの感じ好きなんすよ僕
すげー o
府はフェイが動いている
すごいんだよね今クオリティがいい感じいい感じ
なんでみんな誰かのやつ使うかな某
すげー
うわぁ凄いつがウォッチん分
子は可愛いん
大
おおすごいないん
oo 明日いいなぁ押されたなぁ
最後3 d だー
民族間なる音楽でしたね
関係
もうすごいね距離ティガおおあぁやべーなこれはー
ふぉ会う前は言えばへ
とず乗ってるなぁ
入っている
すげーなーも答えがアニメーションですよねここまで来ると
a
うおおー
馬って初子すぎでしょこれ
ua
4日
ん
これは俗にいう才能の無駄遣いでしっ
はぁっ
颶風口が割れちゃってんじゃん定期のイケ舞強塩基 by けど
おすごいすうーん
かっこよ
俺じゃないよおお
oo
あっ
はシンプルです聞こえの
4 o
ゲームボーイかんな
ヴォースゲーなアニメ超絶好きなんですよね結構
終わりうわああああばばばばやめるのチャンネル登録よろしこじゃないから本当に
コマンドタイプだー
すぎ戦ってるねー共有してねー
おおーー次へ
よくこんなの付けてるなって思いますよ
うんん
大
葉山と[ __ ]でできたよ
ぷううおーー
マイクラですねー
立っ派
死んでモーター
ねええええなんなのこいつの作業で北岳ねー
おおーー
そのと迎える
ゴキブリもいるじゃん
始めた
始まっ本陣ねはじめはじめ8箱ちまっ源基
走り初め源基肇社長
いいで山ねまだやっと半分ぐらいなんですけども
もうねどっちかっていうとね後半にもなかなかすごい人たちが多かったんでコーナーの
方に見どころがあると思います後半
すごいからん
すって
ん
うって